Please welcome Ben Schwartz.
(audience applauds)
Hi, Ben
Oh my god, Drew, we're wearing the same flower.
This is insane.
(Drew and Ross laughing)
Oh, I'm so embarrassed.
I'm mortified.
Ben, I love your accoutrement.
Oh, thank you.
Hello Ross. How are you?
I'm fantastic.
Now I want a flower.
Thanks a lot.
Of course.
You have a big sunflower, look.
Oh I do, (indistinct), perfect!
(audience laughs)
You have the biggest flower of us all.
Thanks for noticing.
(audience laughs)
Ben, this was the first time
you were actually playing a father
and you're not a father in real life.
Tell me about that 'cause I have felt the same way.
It was fun.
Look at that kid,
look how, that's Matilda Lawler
who was on Broadway before she did this movie,
and she's incredible
so it made the whole process amazing.
First day I like,
I took Matilda and threw her really high in the air.
She held onto the rafters
and was like what am I doing?
(Ross laughs)
I did all the wrong dad things.
We were, it was terrible,
but then we got a hang of it,
and it was great.
All right, Ben, will you do some headlines with us?
I can't wait.
I don't know what's about to happen,
and I'm so thrilled.
I can't wait.
We're gonna start with one
that I think you'll be able to get behind.
All right, The Boston Globe reports
that typewriters are making a comeback.
Business is booming for the little shop
called Cambridge Typewriter,
and sales are up by 40%,
and a lot of younger people are coming in
looking for an old clickety clacker.
Ben, what are your thoughts?
This is gonna blow everything,
but I'm not really at a news desk.
I have a series.
I have two different typewriters.
I love typewriters.
It's like one of my favorite things.
Do you actually use them like when you write?
I probably use it maybe twice a week.
I send my friends letters
and I pretend I'm either them from the past
that sent them a letter from like
or it's their grandparents,
or if my friend talks trash
about like an NBA player on Twitter,
I'll pretend I'm that NBA player,
and LeBron James will send that person a note
and be like "How dare you make fun of me on Twitter?"
And stuff like that so it's been very.
Okay, not to be pushy,
but maybe we could be pen pals.
I wanna hear about my past and I like writing letters.
I'm a big fan.
Oh, I cannot wait.
You give me an address.
You will get a letter ASAP.
I can't wait till you get a letter from him.
I know, me too.
I hope it was okay I just was like,
"Ben, we're gonna write each other."
It's gonna be great.
It's good.
Well, this is exciting
because next we're talking peanut butter passion
in today's food news.
Okay.
(Narrator hums)
Delish reports that a recent survey asked people
if they are a creamy peanut butter person
or a crunchy peanut butter person,
and it was split right down the middle 50/50
but people were so passionate
that half of them said they wouldn't even date someone
who liked the other kind,
and to that, I say, come on.
The poll also looked at peanut butter personalities.
Listen to this, creamy types are early birds
and more introverted,
and crunchies are extroverted night owls.
Well, I feel very about peanut butter.
I love it,
and I buy creamy because that's just what I know,
but whenever I have crunchy, I feel like such a bad boy,
you know what I mean?
(Drew laughs)
Yeah.
Right?
You never put a jacket to go out at night.
(Ross laughs)
Can I also give a follow-up question to you guys?
What are your thoughts on tiny spoons?
I love a tiny spoon.
Love a tiny spoon.
I think about this literally every day,
because I do my yogurt parfait in the morning
and I have this one tiny spoon, one of them,
and I will have to wash it every single morning
because it's my only tiny spoon.
You gotta buy another one, Ross.
You earned it.
You deserve it.
Here's a tip, don't eat peanut butter on television.
(audience laughs)
It's the best.
Ben, are you crunchy or creamy?
Are you nice or naughty?
I can do both.
I love both.
Sometimes, one of my things when I'm filming,
if my energy is getting low,
is I get a peanut butter and jelly sandwich
on a whole wheat,
and I usually use creamy for that.
Yeah, I think for a sandwich,
it's too much combativeness with the bread,
you need creamy,
but I just bought a jar.
You cover your mouth when you chew,
you're so polite.
Ross and I are absolute dogs.
(Drew and Ross laughing)
Absolute dogs.
Just maniacs,
rabid dogs eating there (mimmicks).
I told you it's for bad boys.
(Drew and Ben laughing)
What are you?
Are you creamy or crunchy?
I'm both.
I'm a straddler.
(laughs)
I'm naughty and nice
As you've gotten old,
like one side has taken over more or no?
Oh, one side definitely takes over more sometimes.
I get real crunchy sometimes.
(laughs)
But then I also get really creamy sometimes.
(Ross laughs)
I can be like super packed with peanuts
but also I could have none in me, none.
(audience laughs)
I am with you Ben.
And I think you play a fantastic father
in "Flora & Ulysses".
It's available right now on Disney+,
and Ben, we have unfinished business, clickety clack.
Send them up.
I'll do it. I can't wait.
Make sure you write back
Clickety clack, make sure you write back.
Then you'll respond to me or this will be very embarrassing,
and I'll never get a response.
No, pen pals is a two way street.
Okay, I'm gonna smear like peanut butter on the inside
so you know it's me,
so tell people not to be rooted out
if it's like an envelope
like with half peanut butter in it.
It might be the new sealant we were all looking for.
(Ross laughs)
That'll make you wanna lick the envelopes.
All right.
Thank you Ben so much.
We'll be in touch.
(upbeat music)